Great job making it this far into the course.
Let's take a look at the solution to this XORD
exercise. So here's our parse file function, and you
can see that what we've done here, is use this
column slicing trick. We've used the call values method
on sheet to pull out all of the values in
column one. Column one being the coast column within
that data set. Then, we're simply using max and min
here on this list that we've pulled out, in order to get the max val and min
val in that entire column. We're using the index
method on lists, to figure out where that max
val is in the CV list. Now, because the
data that we have actually begins on row one
of the spreadsheet rather than row zero, we've got
to add a one here. So that within our
spreadsheet, we end up with the right position for
that value, that is to say, the right row
number. Okay, then what we're going to do here is
for the position or the row on which the
max value appears, we're going to take the value
in column zero. That will give us the max
time. Okay? And then what we're going to do,
is turn that time, which we'll get as a floating
point number, into an actual time tuple. We'll
do that same process with the min value.
In generating our data dictionary that we'll end
up returning from this function, we can simply
plug in the realtime, maxval, realmintime, and minval,
and then to get the average, we're simply
going to calculate it right here, and make
it the value of this key, avgcoast. Okay,
let's run this. I just want to point out that I'm using the p print
module here, so that we get our data printed out in a nicely structured way.
And we can see that we get good values here.
And if you take a look in the spreadsheet itself
and do something like sort the spreadsheet, you'll see that
the maximum times and the maximum values are calculated correctly. One
thing I want to note is that, in our assertion here,
we're doing a rounding so that we don't have any
issues with floating point values being slightly off as we
get further and further to the right of the decimal point.